let's talk about australia though
because australia something insane is
happening there i mean i'm going to show
you a bunch of stories right now in some
video here australia's just
i don't know what's going on it seems
like they have just decided to just give
up in the face of rampant
authoritarianism so first off we're
going to show you this video this is uh
of a australian grocery store because
people are just basically stocking up on
stuff and there ain't a lot of stuff to
stock up on so first let's show you this
[Music]
look at woolies in her skill
everything
is empty
literally empty
[Music]
hey why is everything empty
this
[Music]
that's crazy man
everything is gone nothing
their trucks aren't coming in
okay so it sounds like there's several
reasons for this and i'm not going to
sit here pretending that i'm an expert
in australian politics although i do
love australia and i and i had such a
wonderful time there with jordan
peterson two greatest weeks of my life
and i love the people there and it's so
sad what's happening it sounds like some
of the reason that this is happening is
that truck drivers are actually
protesting the lockdowns so that they're
not delivering stuff but it does sound
like there's also just which which is
what we're having here there's just like
this log jam in getting things places
and there's less stuff to go around and
everything else but when you see that
that should put chills down your spine
because australia is a first world
nation just like the united states just
like england right and it's like if
supermarkets are going to start going
bare because people are protesting or
because stuff can't get there or because
everyone's locked down and they don't
want you going out and they want you to
order everything on amazon everything
else we got a big freaking problem here
um so we've got a quote here oh so let's
just okay so that's one thing that's one
thing getting a little ahead of myself
here that's one thing well now if you
think that that's sort of scary and
eerie and like oh could that start
happening here well australia is now
building quarantine camps we've got an
image right there i mean this this looks
if you look at what images from nazi
concentration camps look like they
actually look similar the layout is
somewhat similar it's quite quite
disturbing um we've got a quote here uh
sorry where's this quote from um
let's go let's go to the quote from the
age actually
construction is underway at melbourne's
center for national resilience that's
what they named this thing melbourne
center melbourne it's melbourne not
melbourne melbourne center for national
resilience the unwieldy name given to
the new quarantine facility in mickelham
with the camp set up to open by the end
of the year so it's a little unclear to
me and i would gladly
take any of your comments on this
they're gonna these are quarantine camps
so that means if you get covid they're
going to send you to this camp with
other people who have kovid so that you
will not have covet anymore
would these people not be constantly
reinfecting each other and do you think
maybe and again i don't want to be a
crazy conspiracy theorist but do you
think maybe when governments start
moving populations into camps that that
could maybe lead to bad things and that
could maybe
eventually expand the definition of who
should be in the camp and why i mean
should we start having camps for
unvaccinated people and maybe just feed
them fish heads once a week would that
be something that we could do
and if you don't think all of that is
weird enough okay and yes it is weird uh
well now
we've got some video here the australian
federal government is planning to
de-anonymize the internet to introduce a
social credit system for combating
online abuse this is the type of thing
that would have got you banned from
twitter or youtube two years ago if you
would have said this sort of thing that
there's a chinese social credit system
coming that basically uh if you say
things that are anti-government or
against whatever the mainstream media
narrative is that you'd get you know
banned from the internet or that you
wouldn't be able to take part in
commerce and that the government will
literally keep a score on you to see how
what level of a good citizen you are so
here's some video a radical plan to
crack down on social media abuse is
being considered by the federal
government for more nine's oliver hague
joins us live in adelaide ollie how will
it work
well good morning essentially it will
work the same as a passport australians
forced to submit 100 points of
identification like their driver's
license or passport when using social
media accounts like facebook and twitter
now police would have access to those
social media accounts and it's all part
of a crackdown on online abuse now users
could be liable for defamation suits or
even criminal prosecution and it's all
part of a plan hoping to deter people
from engaging in bad behavior now the
recommendations were handed down by a
federal parliamentary inquiry their
reforms that are being considered by the
morrison government with the chairman
saying there is merit to remove
to remove uh the veil of being anonymous
leila
so police will have access to australian
social media accounts to stop bad
behavior
all right so let's do just sort of the
surface level version of it oh well
that's pretty good because people are
mean online and online people who are
anonymous or mean yes that's true now
let's do the slightly uh
slower or under version of this right
the little deeper version of it uh who's
going to decide what bad behavior is is
bad behavior saying that you're against
lockdowns is bad behavior saying you
don't like a government official is bad
behavior saying you want your kids to go
to school
is there an ethical problem
in terms of privacy that the government
can just read all your stuff you know
there's a i think you can argue it both
ways and and i should do more shows on
it i think there's a great philosophical
legal technological uh series of
arguments around anonymity online right
like if you're a let's say you were a
gay person in gaza okay there might be
some value in you being anonymous online
so you can connect with other people
tell people your story maybe meet
somebody
all of that stuff and it's legit you're
under an authoritarian government
australia is supposedly a western
government people are allowed to be
trolls at least for now people are
allowed to post pictures of frogs people
are allowed to make fun of politicians
but really what they're saying is here
is oh we're going to combat hate and
again i don't love hate trust me i i get
more than my fair share of hate online i
assure you that i do so i don't love
that and sometimes it can be quite
annoying because i would say
even though i really don't look at
responses anymore 90
usually of when i would look at this
stuff and get hate it's usually from
anonymous accounts right very few people
will tell you that you're an evil nazi
right-wing lunatic
when you're when it's actually their
picture and you know there's some skin
in the game so i understand why that
there's reasons for anonymity and i
understand why anonymity also creates
problems but if you don't think that
this is a slippery slope sort of like
building camps for the bad people um
then you know i'd like to sell you a
bridge we got a little bit more from
australia i mean it's just crazy this is
from yahoo news
residents in apartment buildings that
have been locked down by australia's new
south wales state health department over
covet 19 concerns say that they have had
their deliveries searched and have had
packages containing alcohol confiscated
if the amount exceeds the department's
prescribed alcohol limit so you're
locking people in their house and you're
saying to them you can't drink
okay now again we can all argue about
how healthy drinking is you know i've
been on this tequila kick and i do like
those malbecs but like so the government
is searching people's packages you think
that might be a problem in apartment
blocks locked down by nsw health
residents are having their alcohol
deliveries policed in accordance with
the department's policy which allows
residents to receive a ration of six
beers or pre-mixed drinks one bottle of
wine or one 375 milliliter bottle of
spirits
according to news.com dot a u you can
have six beers
and you can have one bottle of wine i
mean does any of this sound right to you
this has nothing to do with alcohol at
this point do you see there might be a
problem here it continues any alcohol
outside the limit is being confiscated
until lockdown rules are lifted
according to the report residents may
ask a clinician if they want more than
the prescribed limits i have no doubt
that doctors are being called left and
right
you know i need my gin it helps me sleep
um
lordy guys
there's something so crazy in the system
right now and and i think we're all
running out of time to fight it
all of us we're all running out of time
and and what we need to link this back
to the front story is we all need it
right now i know you need it i need it
we all need it we all need a little bit
of hope